My name is Diakalola Amujam. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK. the declineside application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book, as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey.
我叫Diakalola Amujam。我刚从爱尔兰心理学专业毕业。我也是一名临床心理学家的准从业者。Marion博士的《临床心理学家合集》一书在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中给予了我极大的帮助。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，我发现这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学申请流程的深入信息，这对我来说非常有用。我很喜欢阅读那些已获得资格的临床心理学家和实习生的经历。书中的各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都各不相同，这为临床心理学之旅提供了令人惊叹的见解。
I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. Hi, welcome along to Inner Work. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Now this week's main podcast episode is about neurofeedback and that's with Dr. Madeline Rohntree. And it kind of got me thinking about the idea that we're unfinished versions of ourselves. And I, yeah, I'm always striving to think about how we can make changes. So I think it's not part of the kind of whole Stephen Bartlett kind of optimization of everything narrative. But actually, if there's things, that we recognise that we maybe would welcome being a bit different or feeling a bit different
我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。嗨，欢迎来到《内在工作》（Inner Work）。我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。本周的主要播客节目是关于神经反馈的，嘉宾是Madeline Rohntree博士。这让我开始思考一个观点，即我们都是未完成的自我版本。是的，我一直在努力思考我们如何做出改变。我认为这并不属于那种斯蒂芬·巴特利特（Stephen Bartlett）式的“万物优化”叙事的一部分。但实际上，如果我们意识到有些事情我们可能希望有所不同，或者感觉有所不同，
about, then that can be really useful as a, even just as a starting point. And I think when we're beginning to think about accessing therapy, then it's those things, you know, what would be your goals? What would you change about yourself? And I guess some of the kind of trickier ethics of neurofeedback are, you know, is it okay that we are thinking about changing other people, you know, changing our children, changing the way that they are. And there's been some kind of ethical discussion around that that I seem to remember when I read Sieben Fisher's book and the book by Bessel van der Kolk as well. But yeah, you know, not being finished, it's that idea that our brain has always got this ability to learn. Our habits can change.
那么这作为一个起点是非常有用的。我认为当我们开始考虑寻求治疗时，关键在于：你的目标是什么？你会改变自己的哪些方面？我想神经反馈中一些比较棘手的伦理问题是：我们考虑改变他人，比如改变我们的孩子，改变他们的现状，这样做合适吗？我记得在阅读Sieben Fisher的书以及Bessel van der Kolk的书时，似乎看到过关于这方面的伦理讨论。但确实，我们尚未完成，这体现了我们的大脑始终具备学习能力，我们的习惯可以改变。
our, you know, relational patterns can change. We don't necessarily need to accept this status quo of how it is right now. And I think that's different than saying that you are broken or that someone else is broken. It's having that belief in the ability to change, to adapt, to, I guess, as Madeline was saying, to find that balance, to come back to, I guess a better, a better frequency for you. where you resonate differently with less trauma, I think, in more of an adaptive way. And you might well have written yourself off for things or thought there's nothing I can do about that.
我们的关系模式也可以改变。我们不一定非要接受现状。我认为这与说“你坏掉了”或“别人坏掉了”是不同的。这是一种相信改变和适应能力的信念，我想正如Madeline所说，是为了找到那种平衡，回到一个对你来说更好的频率。在那里，你以一种更具适应性的方式产生共鸣，减少创伤。你很可能已经因为某些事情而否定了自己，或者认为自己对此无能为力。
I know a few weeks ago I spoke about wanting to book a pelvic physio women's health assessment. I am delighted to report that I have taken action, and I'm already seeing changes from some of the recommendations and the physio exercises that the physio gave me. If you'd like to learn more about that, drop me a comment and I will maybe think about making a video about what all of that involved. I think that came about for me
我知道几周前我提到过想预约一次盆底物理治疗和女性健康评估。我很高兴地告诉大家，我已经采取了行动，并且从物理治疗师给出的建议和练习中已经看到了变化。如果你想了解更多相关信息，请给我留言，我会考虑制作一个视频来介绍整个过程。我想这对我来说之所以发生，
because I kind of wasn't prepared to just have that, this is me moment, really, from, you know, the greatest showman. I was like, this is my opinion of what I am like right now, but I would welcome the qualified expert opinion on whether this is just something that I need to put up with. So I think, yeah, get curious.
是因为我真的不想仅仅停留在《马戏之王》里那种“这就是我”的时刻。我当时想，这是我对自己目前状态的看法，但我欢迎合格专家的意见，看看这是否只是我必须忍受的事情。所以，是的，保持好奇心吧。
Maybe don't take your own opinion, unless you are an expert qualified opinion, maybe seek other opinions about whether it might be worth exploring things. And I guess even if you're scoping things out with people around you, that might be a bit of an echo chain, but they might also have the same thoughts and feelings as you. So that's why I think booking a session in with someone who is an expert in that field. So it might be physiotherapy. It might be a cancer. It might be a therapist. It might be a psychologist. Someone that has different experiences that you're going to get a more balanced opinion from,
也许不要只听取你自己的意见，除非你是专家，否则不妨寻求其他意见，看看是否值得探索。我想即使你只是和周围的人探讨，那可能有点像回声室，但他们也可能有和你一样的想法和感受。这就是为什么我认为预约一位该领域的专家进行咨询很有必要。可能是物理治疗师、咨询师、治疗师或心理学家。从拥有不同经验的人那里，你会得到更平衡的意见，
I think can be transformational because then you get the benefit of, of feeling. feeling validated, of feeling understood. And then when you have that, it sort of rallies this inner drive to help you to stay on your track to make changes. I would love your thoughts on this. What behaviour or feeling states would you want to change? Maybe we'll get a little bit cheeky. Is there anything you'd change about someone else?
我认为这可能是变革性的，因为你会获得被认可、被理解的感觉。当你拥有了这些，它会激发你内心的动力，帮助你保持轨道去做出改变。我很想听听你们的想法。你们想改变什么样的行为或感受状态？我们甚至可以调皮一点：有什么你想改变别人的地方吗？
You know, if you could strap on some neurofeedback electrodes and be like, let's get rid of that thing, what would it be? I would love your thoughts. Thank you so much for being a listener, a watcher for inner work. I will look forward to bringing you the next episode, which will be along next week. Thank you again. I'll see you soon. Take care. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee, psychological well-being practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
你知道，如果你能戴上神经反馈电极，说“让我们摆脱那个东西”，那会是什么？我很想听听你们的想法。非常感谢大家收听、收看《内在工作》。我期待着在下周为大家带来下一期节目。再次感谢。再见，保重。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现书中关于人们如何成为临床心理学家的各种故事非常有趣。这么多不同的途径让我感到惊讶，成为临床心理学家并没有完美的路径。这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它会让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。